to remove fat from your liver just drink
this one cup every single day now I know
you're saying no freaking way is this
going to work but just hear me out it'll
make sense most of the fat on our livers
is coming because of insulin resistance
okay and out of all the things that are
very powerful to help reverse insulin
resistance apple cider vinegar is at the
top of the list what you're simply going
to do is take a glass of water and
you're going to add one tablespoon of
apple cider vinegar my favorite is Fair
child's not brags because brags dilutes
their apple of vinegar then you're going
to add to it lemon juice you can do a
tablespoon of lemon juice or just
squeeze the juice from an actual lemon
the combination of lemon which by the
way helps to remove fat off your liver
and apple ceter vinegar which helps you
with insulin resistance can put you in a
condition where your body actually
releases the fat from the liver for the
complete information of why this works
check out my YouTube channel